Merhabalar
[Alkış]
Evet bugün yine ben de biraz
sevimli olmayan konularla devam ediyorum
Ama söz veriyorum sonunda güzel bir yere
bağlayacağım
şimdi yok oluş dediğimizde ya da 6 yok
oluş İçinde bulunduğumuz yok oluş süreci
dediğimizde
belki çoğumuzun aklına gelecekte çok
uzak bir zamanda gerçekleşecek ve belki
de bir günde gerçekleşecek adeta bir
kıyamet günü gibi gerçekleşecek bir olay
geliyor
ama Aslında bakarsanız durum pek öyle
değil
İçinde bulunduğumuz altıncı yok oluş
dünyanın daha önceki zamanlarda
karşılaştığı beş şok oluştan farklı
olarak bu sefer insan etkisiyle
gerçekleşiyor ve aslına bakarsanız çok
gelecekte ya da bir günde bir anda değil
her gün
kendini gösteriyor ve giderek de bunu
hissetmeye devam ediyoruz
Tabii yok oluş direkt başta aklınıza
türlerin yok oluşu geliyor insan
dışındaki türler her gün katlanan
sayılarda artıyor artarak yok oluyor
maalesef
her sene bir sonraki senenin
yok olma tehlikesiyle karşı karşıya olan
türlerini açıklıyoruz işte bir sonraki
sene bu türlerden çoğunu kaybettiğimizi
açıklıyoruz
bununla beraber iklim krizinin artık
eşiğinde değiliz tam içindeyiz iklim
krizi de genelde sanki böyle Gelecekte
bir zaman olacak bir şeymiş gibi
algılanıyor ama hayır artık evlerimize
kadar geldi Daha önceden bilim insanları
uyarıyordu fakat Çoğu kişi bunu inkar
etmeyi seçiyordu belki ama yaşanan
ekstrem hava olayları özellikle yazları
yangınlarla karşılaşıyoruz kışları
sellerle karşılaşıyoruz iklim krizinde
aslında tam olarak ortasında olduğumuzu
iyiden iyi anlamaya başladık
ve sadece insanlar olarak
bizim dışımızdaki hayvan türleri ile ya
da doğayla değil kendi içimizde de Savaş
halindeyiz her gün bir haberi uyanıyoruz
her gün birileri birileriyle savaşıyor
her gün birileri ölüyor her gün bir
başka savaşın olabileceğinden korkuyoruz
günümüzde bu kadar zaman
ilerlediğimizi iddia ederken hala
nükleer tehlikesinden korkuyoruz Örneğin
hala mantıklı davranamayacağımızdan
korkuyoruz belki de
şimdi bu tablo
Aslında gerisinde çok daha ciddi bir
soruna işaret ediyorsa ve aslında bütün
bu olanlar ya bizi uyarmak için ortaya
çıkan krizlerse
şimdi insanlar olarak tür olarak bir
hikayeleri çok seviyorum diyebilirsiniz
ki yani hikayeleri sevmek neden kötü
olsun hikayeler güzel şeylerdir genelde
ama bir hikayeyi kendiniz yazıp buna
hakikatten daha çok inandığınız zaman
işte orada sorun başlıyor
işte insanlığın inandığı en büyük
hikayelerden biri de kendinin
gezegendeki bütün türlerden üstün olduğu
hikayesi bunu resmen mutlak bir
gerçeklik olarak çoğu insan maalesef
kabul etmiş durumda ve dünya bu
zihniyetin çatısı altında işliyor
şimdi baktığımızda ne diyor işte
insanlık Ben her şeyin üstündeyim bütün
türlerin üstündeyim ve dolayısıyla her
şeyin üstünde olduğum için onlar
üzerinde tahakküm kurabilirim onları
kullanabilirim kendi çıkarım için
sömürebilirim onları istediğim her şeyi
yapabilirim Hatta onları yok edebilirim
Kendimde bu Hakkı görüyorum diyor
Peki bunu neye dayandırıyor çok zeki
oluşuna
Aslında bakarsanız Zeka çok Göreceli bir
kavram nereden baktığınıza bağlı yani
bugün insan Zeki oluşunu aya gidiyor
olabilmesi ile ölçülüyorsa ve atıyorum
bir sincabın aya gidemediği için
kendisinden daha az zeki olduğunu iddia
ediyorsa Aslında tamamen yanlış yerden
bakıyor olaya
Çünkü insan Aya gitmek istediği için aya
gidebiliyor ama sincabın ayak gitmekte
bir çıkarı yok ki ve insan Belki de aya
giderken bir sürü bir sürü şeye zarar
veriyor kendine zarar veriyor olmaması
gereken yerlere gitmeye çalışıyor
yapmaması bulunmaması gereken yerlerde
bulunuyor Yani baktığımızda zeka oldukça
Göreceli bir kavram
bununla beraber zekayı
belirli şartlarda ve belirli durumlarda
en Optimum ve en faydalı şeyleri yapmak
olarak tanımlarsak
o zaman insanın kendi kendine yok etmesi
ne kadar zekice
bunu kendimize sorabiliriz
ya da insan diğer türlerden zeki
olduğunu iddia ediyor işte Zeki
olduğumuz için
bazı türlere bazı şeyleri yapma hakkımız
var onları yiyebiliriz kullanabiliriz
giyebiliriz onlara her türlü işkence
yapabiliriz onlar üzerine deneyler
yapabiliriz
Peki biz diğer hayvanlardan iyi ve doğru
olanı yanlıştan ayırabileceğimizi iddia
ediyorken Bugün 21 yüzyılda aslında
bunları yapmayacak kapasitemiz varken
teknolojimiz varken olanağımız
alternatifimiz varken
bu acıları tekrar ve tekrar yaşatmak ve
sürdürülemez bu sistemi devam ettirmenin
neresi zekice
kendimize bu soruları sorabiliriz şimdi
zeka dan bahsederken Tabii
günümüzde de çok artan
oranda bir Yapay Zeka tartışması var
biliyorsunuz şu anda bütün Yapay Zeka
çalışan insanlar ve bu konuda konuşan
insanlar tartışan insanlar çok ciddi
uyarılarda bulunuyorlar nedir bu
uyarılar yapay zekanın her an kontrolden
çıkabileceği Hatta kontrolden çıkmış
oldu Şu an Yapay Zeka daha önce olmadığı
gibi kendi kendine üretebiliyor yani
Yapay Zeka başka yapay zekalar
üretebiliyor Bunun nesi
alarmda olmamız gereken nokta Normalde
insan yapay zekayı kontrol ediyordu ya
da insan icatları kontrol ediyordu ve
bir icat başka bir icadı doğuramıyordu
Yani bir nükleer silah yaptığınızda o
yaptığınız nükleer silah Başkan nükleer
silahlar yapamıyordu ama şimdi durum
böyle değil Yapay Zeka kendine göre
Terek başka yapay zekalar üreterek
insanlığın
Aslında en büyük tehditi ve korkusu
haline gelmiş durumda hali hazırda
çoğunuz sosyal medyada görmüşsünüzdür
photoshop'ta Yapay Zeka uygulamasıyla
artık grafiker insanların işlerin
elinden alacağı bir sürü alanda yavaş
yavaş artık insanlara ihtiyacı
kalmayacak ile alakalı çok ciddi böyle
kaygılar var
şimdi insanlığın bana bu kaygısı yine
kendinin kim olduğuyla alakalı bir
yansıma gibi geliyor Çünkü Normalde
baktığınız zaman Aslında bir sürü
tarihçi bir sürü bilim insanı diyor ki
yani durabiliriz
yapay zekayı etik bir şekilde çalışır
hale getirebiliriz bunu İçinde
bulunduğumuz krizlerin çözümü için
kullanabiliriz ama durmuyoruz Tıpkı
kendi zekamızı iyi ya da kötü
kullanabileceğimiz gibi Yapay Zeka ya da
kötü kullanmaktan korkuyoruz Aslında
kendimizden korkuyoruz
Çünkü zeka baktığınızda bir araç İyi de
kullanabilirsiniz kötü de
kullanabilirsiniz
Yapay Zeka dışında beni her zaman
düşündüren ve hani insanların belleğinde
yaratmış Bir de şey söylemi vardır ya
işte Uzaylılar gelecek ve bize çok kötü
şeyler yapacaklar Çünkü Uzaylılar bunu
yapabilir Çünkü onlar bizden daha zeki
daha zeki daha üstün bizim üzerimizde
tahakküm kurabilirler Aslında
korktuğumuz şey yine kendi yaptığınız
davranışların bir yansıması çünkü bizde
bizim dışımızdaki hayvanları aynı şeyi
yapıyoruz Aslında onlar bizden daha az
zeki olduğu için bizim tarafımızdan bir
sürü zulme uğruyorlar yine aynı şeyin
başımıza başka daha zeki formlar
tarafından geleceğini düşünüyoruz Yine
kendini yansımamızdan korkuyoruz
şimdi geçtiğimiz haftalarda mezun
olduğum lisede yine böyle bir eko Fest
gibi bir etkinlik kapsamında bir konuşma
yapma şansım oldu ve orada Aslında yine
insan merkezciliğini insan
üstünlükçülüğünü ve türcülüğün dünyayı
ne kadar zor duruma soktuğunu bütün Biz
kendimizle dahil bütün canlıları çok
ciddi bir yok oluşa doğru
sürüklediğinden bahsediyordum
sonra bir öğrenci el kaldırdı ve şey
dedi
ama dedi bütün bu hani kötü işte
özelliklerinin yanı sıra sonuçlarının
yanı sıra hala üstünüz ama değil mi dedi
yani çünkü bir hayvanla aynı olamayız
değil mi dedi yani
peki dedim hani farkımız ne Biz de
aslında bu gezegende diğer türlerden bir
tanesiyiz
farklılıklarımız bizi İlla Üstün mü
yapmak zorunda ya da
üstünlük dediğimizde Neyi kastediyoruz
ve ona dedim ki; Eğer sen birinden üstün
olduğunu düşünüp ve bu üstünlükten bir
şekilde vazgeçmek istemiyorsan Ama bu
üstünlüğü Sana kötü bir şeyler
yaptırmaması gerektiğini düşünüyorsan O
zaman bana üstünlük deme buna farklılık
de ve senin farklılığın Bu dünyaya bir
katkı olsun bir zarar olmasın bir eksi
olmasın Aslında evrimsel sürece
baktığımız zaman tam olarak bu şekilde
işlemiyor ama her türün kendi farklılığı
birbirinden Üstün olmadan tam olarak
yapması gereken şeyi yapıyor ve bu
dünyada beraber belirli bir uyum içinde
var olabiliyoruz alt üst ilişkisinin
devam ettirerek
Evet ve yok oluşun Tabi bir başka
altında yatan zihniyet O da durmadan
tüketmemiz gerektiği homo konsümer
artık yani bizi tanımlayan şey
biliyorsunuz tüketici olmamız sürekli
tüketmek zorundayız şu anda İçinde
bulunduğumuz mevcut ekonomik düzen
sonsuz büyüme ve sonsuz tüketim
öngörüyor Ancak bu şekilde ayakta
kalabileceğini söylüyor Hatta ve hatta
olası bir krizde Durul
Mada durulmayalım daha fazla tüketelim
Ne yapalım da budurulmayı hemen aşalım
diye düşünüyoruz
kendimize soralım çok basit ve mantık
sorusu sınırlı olan bir şeyi sonsuz bir
şekilde tüketirseniz ne olur
yapamazsınız sonu gelmez bana çökersiniz
ve çöktüğünüzü bilmezsiniz
maalesef işinde yaşadığınız durum bu
Evet Eduardo
uruguaylı bir yazar ve gazeteci
bu sözünü çok seviyorum
Doğa Eğer bir banka olsaydı onu çoktan
kurtarmışlardı
şimdi diyebilirsiniz ki yani abartma
herhalde bankadan daha fazla önem
vereceğiz doğaya tabi ki de
şirketlerin şu an doğadan ve insan dışı
hayvanlardan daha fazla hakkı var yasal
olarak bugün siz bir ırmağa gidip bir
ırmağı kirlettiğinizde o ırmakta yaşayan
balıkları canlıları neyse o
ekosistemdeki hayvanlar ölümüne sebep
olduğunuzda bir ağacı kestiğinizde
Sokakta bir hayvanı zehirlediğinizde
ya mala zarardan belki ceza alırsınız ya
da almazsınız
ama bir şirket
rekabet hukuku gereği
size reklamlarıyla açık açık yalan
söylediğinde buna sadece şirketin ismini
vererek bir eleştiri getirdiğinizde size
dava açılır
işte içinde
yaşayan en büyük sorunlarından biri
bence bu
canlı olmayan bir yaşamayan entitileri
varlıkları tamamen kurgusal varlıkları
yaşayan canlı nefes alan acı çeken
hayatın kendisinden daha üstün görüyoruz
Evet biraz önce bahsetmiştim
Home tüketici
şimdi zannetmeyin ki bu sistem sadece
İşte insan dışı hayvanları ya da doğayı
etkiliyor bize çok güzel şeyler yapıyor
işte Bizi düşünüyor biz ne kadar güzel
tükete tükete böyle harika bir dünyada
yaşıyoruz Hayır ya bu sistem bizi de
kullanıyor
Buna göre bizim kim olduğumuz neye
ihtiyacımızın olduğu iyilik halimiz
bunların hiçbirini düşündükleri yok
aslında bizi tanımlayan şey bugün
yaşadığımız ekonomik düzende Tüketim
alışkanlıklarımızın ne kadar
tükettiğimiz her seferinde daha fazla
tüketmeye teşvik ediliyoruz
tükettiğimiz ölçüde Kale alınıyoruz
tüketmek için kaynağımız varsa eğer bir
şekilde haklarımız çok daha iyi bir
şekilde saman oluyor
Yani aslında baktığımız zaman bu
sistemde bizi de ölçüyor ve bir yandan
sizin
duramamanızdan yani sadece tüketici
pozisyonda değilseniz aslında bir de
çalışan pozisyonunda Bir nevi modern
köle pozisyonundasınız Çünkü neden
durmamanız isteniyor dinlenmemenizi
isteniyor Her geçen gün daha az izin
alın sürekli daha çok çalışın evde de
çalışın gece gündüz çalışın sorgulamayın
düşünmeyin düşünecek gibi olursanız
Hemen internete girin bir ürün aratın o
ürünü satın alan unutun ertesi gün gene
her şey aynı devam
peki Hani bu kadar
terslikler oluyor işte her açıdan
düşünebilirsiniz sadece ekolojik
ekolojik çöküş ya da yok oluş değil yani
hani
gündemimizde bir sürü mesela var bazen
diyoruz ki yani bu kadar şey olurken
yanlış şey olurken Neden insanlar olarak
biz bunu değiştiremiyoruz ya sanki bir
yöne doğru böyle kaptırmış gidiyoruz
şimdi otorite çelişkisi diye bir kavram
var
psikolojide bu şuna işaret ediyor en
basit haliyle
Biz bir karar verirken Otoritenin
direktifleri tarafından
kararınız Manipüle oluyorsa ve sırf
otorite öyle söylüyor diye bir şeye
karar veriyorsanız İşte o otorite
çeviricisi oluyor şimdi bunu sadece bu
arada otorite figürleri olarak
düşünmeyin işte ne bileyim devletler
kurumlar şirketler
otorite figürleri toplumdaki olarak
düşünmeyin insanlığa da bir otoritesi
var Çünkü insanlar olarak kendimize de o
kadar fazla özgüveniniz var ki ya
insanlık yapıyorsa Doğrudur bir sürü
insan bunu yapıyorsa yanlış olamaz
hep Aslında gerçeği görmekten Biz
engelleyen düşünce biçimleri bunlar
şimdi otorite ile ilgili psikolojik
araştırmalar İkinci Dünya Savaşının
sonunda
Nazi kaybettikten sonra
rütbe Nazi subaylarının yargılamalarıyla
böyle bir şekilde alevleniyor
Çünkü bu subayları yargılarken
kendilerine yaptıkları insanlık suçları
gösteriyor ve diyorlar ki siz İnsanlık
suçu işlediniz bu Baba bu suçlardan
yargılanacaksınız diyorlar
ve bu kişiler Bu askerler bu subaylar
savunmalarına şunu söylüyorlar biz
yanlış bir şey yapmadık ki biz sadece
emirlere uyduk
60'larda Bu bahsettiğim
yargılama süreçlerinin akabinde tabi
psikoloji Dünyası bu otoriteye uymak ve
Hani körü körüne uymak konusuna giderek
daha fazla araştırmak istiyor ve bunu en
Belki de
popülerleşmiş şekilde araştıranda
stand-i gram oluyor sitede miligram
diğer Üniversitesinde bir profesör
psikoloji profesörü ve bir deneyi
tasarlıyor bu deneyde
şurada görmüş olduğunuz Sol üst köşede
işte profesörün kendisi var experimenter
Sonra Denek var bu deneye şunu
söylüyorlar Aslında otorite ile alakalı
bir deneyin yapacaklarını söylemiyorlar
sadece diyorlar öğrenme ile alakalı bir
deney yapacağız
öğrenme ve hafıza bu Denek Teacher
olacak öğretmen olacak ve diyorlar şeyin
odanın diğer tarafında da bir öğrenci
var siz ona soru soracaksınız öğrenci
bilemezse sorduğunuz soruları ona
belirli şekilde benim komutan eşliğinde
belirli şekilde elektrik şoku
vereceksiniz
o duvarın arkasında aslında bir kişi yok
bir teybe kaydediyorlar o kişinin işte
sözcükleri nasıl cümlelerine
ve baktığınız zaman aslında hani şey
bekleriz belki kişi işte Canım çok
acıyor lütfen yapma hani buradan çıkmak
istiyorum Ne olur bana elektroşok verme
dediğinde
o kişilerin deneklerin durmasını
bekleriz fakat deneyin sonucunda
deneye katılanların üçte ikisinin
ölümcül olabilecek dozlara kadar
gittiğine ve tamamen otoriteye %100 gözü
kapalı bir şekilde
inandığını ve bu dedektifleri
uyguladığını görüyorlar
ve seninle miligram deneyi tamamladıktan
sonra
yazdığı ve makalede diyor ki
Ben diyor saf otoriteyle güçlü vicdani
duyguları çeliştirdim ve çok büyük
çoğunluğuna saf otorite kazandı bu
çelişki de
o zaman diyor çok bizim çok ciddi
anlamda bu otoriteye insanların bu kadar
körü körüne itaat etmesine çok ciddi
anlamda araştırmamız lazım Çünkü bu çok
tehlikeli bir durum diyor şimdi
biz çelişkilerle yaşıyoruz Aslında ve
biraz önce bahsettiğim otorite çelişkisi
ya da yaşadığımız yerden
kendimizi göremememiz durumu bize çok
kötü şeyler yaptırıyor şimdi o zamanlar
işte Nazar almanyasında bütün bu
emirlere Uyan insanlara sorsanız yanlış
bir şey olmadığını size söylerlerdi
Çünkü batmakta olan bir gemiden
baktığınızı çok rahat bir şekilde
göremeyebilirsiniz ama aradan zaman
geçtikten sonra olayın dışına çıkıp
oraya doğru baktığınız zaman Aslında
yanlışları görebiliyoruz ve insanlık
öyle zannedildiği gibi süt sadece süper
başarılarla her şeyin çok doğru
yapıldığı şeylerle dolu değil İnsanlık
çok ciddi Kolektif hatalarla dolu işte
bunu anlamaya başladığımızda aslında
biraz daha bir şeylerin değişmesi
gerektiğini de anlıyoruz
şimdi o insanlara sorduklarında onlar
sadece direktiflere uyduklarını
söylemişlerdi
Bundan 20 30 40 50 yıl sonra belki bize
sorduklarında neden bütün bu olanlara
müdahale etmediğiniz neden daha fazla
ses çıkarmadınız neden değiştirmediğiniz
bir şeyler dediklerinde İşte biz biz
emirlere uyduk dememeliyiz biz hiç
düşünmedik biz sadece bize denileni
yaptık dememeliyiz
gerçekten olası yapmamız gereken
gücümüzü elimize almak
Çünkü otoritelerin dışında Bizim kendi
bir gücümüz de var Her ne kadar bunu
kaybetsek de
bu güç meselesini Yani bir insanın
hayatla alakalı bir değişime yol
açabileceğine inanması meselesine Ben
uzun zaman hayatımda açıkçası
inanmamıştım çocukluğumdan girmeli
yaşlarımı sonlarına kadar Hayatla ilgili
hiçbir şey değiştiremeyeceğimi
düşünüyordum ve sürekli bir şeylerden
kaçıyordum yani sürekli
kendimi Kötü hissediyordum kötü
hissettikçe kendimi uyuşturmaya
çalışıyordum her şeyden kaçıyordum
yok oluş derken işte sadece Aslında bu
gezegen Yok olmuyor sizin kendinizi olan
inancınız
kimlikleriniz bu dünyayı
değiştirebilmeye olan inancınız ya da
gücünüz de yok oluyor Bir Anda
Ama şunu görmek Bence hepimizi
iyileştirecek Bu yaşadığımız şeydeki
dünyadaki hiçbir Hikaye Böyle Doğanın
kanunu ya da değiştirilemez şeyler değil
Hepsi insanlar olarak bizim uydurduğumuz
şeyler bunu değiştirebiliriz Yeter ki
gücümüzün farkına varalım ve bir şeyin
yanlış olduğunu bir kere işaret
ettiğimizde artık oradan geri dönüş
olmaz ve değişim kesinlikle başlamış
demektir teşekkürler
[Alkış]